[Musique]
à chacun vanina seze amis filochard et
un problème faut regarder la télé la
belle mais si on part tous les grands
cris le père la mère le fils pourtant ça
l'esprit m'ont balancée comme plein
visage tout le restant du fromage en
nous traitant de navarre
c'est tout le mal qu'on puisse causer
tranquillement quand la démarche et les
cloches à inwi vous connu filochard à
brest pendant son service militaire dans
la marine
non mais ça sera le pas j'attrape un
c'est pas vrai ça chamonix oui mais
après s'il attendait de bateaux pour les
ou à bordeaux avant d'où ils vont
s'asseoir face à face à chamonix est né
à bordeaux il ya un train direct pour
chamonix et je mettrai directs bordeaux
chamonix jamais trains directs bordeaux
chamanique jeu mu trains directs dans de
chamonix partez pas lui elle était
possible et vous les avez vous connu
filochard les mers du sud à mettet
pêcheurs des pages il a fait ça
longtemps juste une plongée et après
apprendre la ranimer avant il est revenu
en france non non il est parti en
turquie ouvrir une boulangerie pourquoi
ouvrir une boulangerie en turquie parce
que de fermer c'est d'ailleurs là bas
qu'il a connu sa première femme à sa
famille turque non au boulanger
ah oui c'est vrai quelle bonne pente or
et lui qu'il appelait sans cesse mamie
mehdi dow est il connu sa seconde femme
et en épousant la première commence à
arcis parce que sa deuxième femme et la
fille de sa première femme
alors on s'est mis les bouts et sa belle
fille et sa femme est devenue sa belle
mais voilà c'est ça sa belle mère avait
tu sa fille avec son premier mari
oui celui qui est homme grenouille à
vous l'avez connue non mais rien qu'à
voir la fille labo yeux un peu grandir
un berliet je roule pour vous elle est
quand même plus joli que son mari par
faut dire que le mari elle aidé en dira
clavier de piano mais ça vraiment le
clavier de piano le clavier alors sans
les blanches est le fils de deux fils
le pic était si son appui le beau temps
c'était fils sa belle-fille serait que
c'était un presse papier et non non non
c'est un enfant ils s'en servent comme
voie de la paix mais c'est ingrat enfin
atteint repas gastronomique ce repas et
l'apéritif averti que j'ai la recette
savez la recette non jean cabot cognac
un quart de décharge le haut de benzène
un quart de jus de tomate un coeur de
limonade et un quart de bris ça fait
cinq quarts mais ça se voit dans les
grands verres et lorsque nous sommes
passés à ta guitare que moi je suis
passé sous la table vous avez trop bu ou
à peine mais il manquait un pied à ma
chaise et alors moule à manqué de jus
pas tomber n'est pas retombée ben je
voyais double passion ne vois pas le
rapport c'est très simple une seule à
quatre pieds oui elle manquait deux ans
restait 2 comme le vélo ça faisait
quatre oui mais moi aussi je voyais
double et pourtant je suis tombé parce
que vous restez acceptiez lorsqu'on
prend rien du tout je recommence une
chaîne quatre pieds oui quand wade ou ça
fait 8
oui effectivement chrestos est pourquoi
le pays qui manquent en compte par
habana aura pourquoi un pays qui manque
quand on va là où ça fait de pki mort
est alors alors deux pays qui manquent
de cette pécresse a fait neuf pieds mais
j'ai vu une chose à 9,6 bon c'est bon
alors ensuite servi la soupe aux
biscotte
mais non c'était mort des biscottes
c'était des spontex c'était bien fraîche
rhmani et bien moi de la soupe j'en ai
repris non si sur mon costume à vous
avez pu le détacher oui avec l'apéritif
à un résultat plus de tâches non un
grand trou puis nous avons eu leur
hospice orange vif d'une tendreté de la
bouillie ces personnes je les mange et
la petite cuillère oui moi j'ai mis mon
verger fini qu'une paille et les petits
pois c'était du guide était faire ça
porte bonheur
alors on nous a pas servis de fromage
non les venu tout seul et nous avons
terminé par la crème renversée quoi
manger par terre et cette joyeuse
ambiance que cette soirée se poursuit
brand demo même on allait réjouit la
belle mère épuisée ronfle comme un
diesel veut les piquets dans sa crème au
caramel le père la mère les yeux comme
des scènes aussi l'épisode à solwezi
c'est le moutard
c'est même un recond risques oser pro
qu'il ment quand la télé marché les fils
en chat
[Musique]